i find it really this just going back to
this h4 move
um and and this is probably it's
probably one of those openings that has
only become it's a newish opening right
you don't really get new openings and
the idea of h4 is i i still find it
quite amazing how it's caught on uh at a
higher level uh this this move to be
honest i mean uh out of all openings but
i think the thing you you mentioned
which i've never really thought about
alex of playing h6 against the king's
indian as well set up let's say
if you get this kind of thing um
i mean everyone goes on about alpha zero
would would i mean i wouldn't have
thought of putting the pawn on h6 i
would have probably thought of you know
trying to take on g6 but is that is that
do you did you get some inspiration from
alpha zero yourself i mean looking at
the games as is that did it did it
change your way of playing at all or or
your way of looking at chess
okay basically uh i want to make video
at some point
alpha zero pawn before alpha zero
and just to make like collection of my
games where the pawn was pushed to h6 h3
a6 a3 yeah
before alpha 0
appeared yeah because for me it looks in
most cases quite logical and i'm sure
for many players as well so i may be
disagreeing with this
okay alpha zero thing for me it's just
uh
you know good chess so it was basically
around well before our alpha zero alpha
zero took all the credit the stupid
machine so uh i mean i mean i mean if i
make this video about all the pawn
pushes it will be just uh it will take
forever because like larson pushed to
those asian apon
yeah a lot of great players so my point
is just to make my games with this
because
to make it like last reasonable amount
of